bearing it's 17 feet in diameter and
it's housing the 21 satellites that were
flying today the fairing's job is to
protect the satellites from aerodynamic
heating loads and contamination during
the ascent phase of the mission
once we reach the vacuum of space the
fairing has done its job so we'll
actually jettison them back to planet
Earth while the second stage continues
to its final destination in low earth
orbit now again we will have two
deployment sequences during today's
Mission the first deployment sequence
will deploy all five of the Iridium
satellites and the second one will
deploy excuse me and the first six one
web satellites and then in the second
deployment we'll we'll deploy the
additional 10 on One web satellites on
today's flight
below the payload fairing we have the
second stage it has a Merlin vacuum or
mvac engine that's used to take the 21
spacecraft into low earth orbit the mvac
that we're flying today is the uh has a
shortened nozzle and we'll get a pretty
good look at that following stage
separation short nozzle made its debut
on transporter 7 and will continue to be
used on missions that require less
performance
now the bottom two-thirds of the vehicle
is called the first stage it's also
referred to as the booster and at the
its very bottom we've got those nine
Merlin 1D engines that'll get Falcon 9
off the ground off the launch pad and
into the center parts of the Earth's
atmosphere shortly after the liftoff the
first and second stages will separate
from one another and then the second
stage will continue to orbit while the
first stage will start making its way
back down to planet Earth now the first
stage is designed to be reflown with
minimal refurbishment between flights in
fact today's first stage is flying for
its 11th time and we will be attempting
a landing on our drone ship named of
course I still love you it's out in the
Pacific Ocean about 650 kilometers
downrange and if we're successful
that'll Mark the 193rd recovery of an
orbital class rocket
now today's launch consists of two
primary customers we've got both iridium
and one web aboard iridium is a global
satellite Communications company and
they provide access to voice and data
services anywhere on planet Earth now
for our long time viewers you may know
that SpaceX completed a series of eight
launches for iridium that completed back
in 2019 but here four years later we're
happy to be working with iridium again
to send another upgraded five spare
satellites into space these extra
satellites will increase iridium's
constellations resiliency bringing the
number of spare satellites in orbit to
14 and their total constellation size to
80 satellites so with that let's learn a
little bit more about iridium and the
satellites that they're flying on Falcon
9 today
innovation
versatility
safety
resilience
these are just a few of the words that
represent iridium
millions of people know they can trust
iridium to connect them to and from
anywhere on the planet every day
as a result
when family friends and colleagues
Venture Off the Grid including to the
world's most dangerous environments they
choose to stay connected with iridium
and some are researching climate change
combating poaching cleaning plastic from
the oceans and ensuring critical Aid can
be safely delivered to those in need
this is what iridium was made for
most important
iridium is a Lifeline for those in dire
situations and it Remains the only
satellite Network that lets you send out
an SOS from anywhere on Earth
we take this responsibility and the
trust place in iridium very seriously
our upgraded satellite constellation
packed with redundancy in space and on
the ground is a testament to our
unwavering commitment to those relying
on us today and the millions more to
come in the years ahead
the original iridium satellite
constellation lasted over 20 years well
beyond what was expected we designed our
latest constellation to even higher
standards with even more flexibility
that's why today you can expect iridium
to continue delivering the highest
quality service in any weather condition
across the whole planet well into the
next decade and Beyond
quite simply there is no network like
iridium
now one web is also a main customer on
today's Mission today's launch will
actually Mark oneweb's 19th overall and
their fourth launch with SpaceX once
these 16 one web satellites on board the
second stage deploy it'll bring their
constellation to 634 satellites in total
now among these 16 satellites there's
also a special demonstration satellite
named Joey sat it's going to test an
Innovative beam hopping capability
allowing satellites to switch the
direction and strength of signals based
on customer needs or demands here's some
extra information about oneweb and the
payloads they're flying today
think for a moment about what
connectivity brings you
is it helping you manage or grow a
business stay in contact with family and
friends is it giving you or your family
access to education or to a doctor is it
opening doors for you to a world Beyond
Your Horizon
of course for many of us in big cities
and large and established communities
it's doing that every day it's essential
fundamental it's enabling Our Lives
from connectivity flows a better quality
of life New Horizons and greater
opportunities so what can we do to help
ensure everybody can experience the
benefits of connectivity
this is the one web mission to bridge
that digital divide to serve businesses
and Rural communities to further
scientific understanding and
collaboration
and we're doing this by bringing
high-speed broadband internet from space
to places where this opportunity was
previously unimaginable every customer
connected by the one web network has
their own story all of them are united
by one thing gaining the power of
connectivity and the independence or
sense of community that can bring one
web launch 19 with SpaceX will fly 15
satellites into our Leo constellation in
addition a 16 satellite will be included
that we have called Joey's that Joey
said is a demonstration satellite which
incorporates several features sets to be
included in oneweb's Next Generation
constellation including beam hopping
technology hence the name Joey this
satellite has been developed alongside
our partners satisfy through our Sunrise
program funded by the European space
agency and the UK space agency we can't
wait to see it in space go oneweb
now we're just about T minus five
minutes away from our launch attempt
today next major Milestone will actually
be for the transporter erector you can
actually make it out on your screen it's
that trust looking structure to the
right of the vehicle on the te we've got
clamps around the top of the seconds
actually call out there on the loops
that we're pressing for strong back
retract so strong back the strong back
is another way that we refer to the
transporter erector we're gonna be
opening up the clamp arms around the top
of the vehicle and then the transport
erector will begin to recline away from
falcon 9. now the te is actually what we
route the propellant loading and
electrical connections to the vehicle
with and it's actually how we also raise
Falcon 9 into this vertical launch
position and as we get to the T minus
zero Mark the ground hydraulic systems
will pull the te away even further
clearing the way for Falcon 9's liftoff
at this point the clamp arms should be
in the process of opening
uh if it wasn't so foggy you'd be able
to see it underneath the top of the
vehicle there but we can actually start
to make out Falcon 9's features here at
the very top of the vehicle you can see
the fairing where we've got the 21
satellites today that white bit below it
is the second stage and then the city
bit below that is Falcon 9's first stage
now the first stage is connected to the
launch Mount at the very base of the te
but the transporter erector is a hinge
structure and retracts away from the
vehicle in preparation for launch
we've actually begun the strong back
retract sequence
you can see it beginning to pull away
from the vehicle there that'll complete
uh just under three T minus three
minutes
taking a quick look at propellants we
are fully
we are fully loaded on our rp1 kerosene
of fuel on both the first and second
stage
and we are completing up liquid oxygen
loading
and second stages call out there that
stage one liquid oxygen loading is
complete
when propellants are fully loaded we'll
have about a million pounds of our fuel
and oxidizer on board
and propellant loading sequence we
started that around the T-minus 35
minute Mark there was a go no-go poll
from the ground team there to step into
it so now we're finishing up propellant
loading on the first stage
and on the second stage
uh we'll expect to complete that in
about the next 30 seconds
and we're starting to get better and
better views clearer views of Falcon 9
Vandenberg of course famous for the fog
that tends to roll in from the coast and
blanket
the launch site
in nice layers of clouds
they play the launch weather continues
to look fantastic for today's launch
attempt
and of course Falcon 9 has onboard
cameras so if we do end up going today
we will probably get some pretty
fantastic views of the California coast
and that fog rolled over on the
Vandenberg coastline
stage two lock flow complete
so call out there that propellant
loading is complete on both the first
and second stages coming up we may see
some venting from the transporter
director you can see a plume of gas
there coming out we're just clearing out
the lines on the transporter erector
there in preparation for launch X major
Milestone will come up at the T-minus 60
second mark
that'll be where Falcon 9 transitions
into startup that meaning its flight
computers will have taken over to the
launch countdown and then at T minus two
seconds we'll ignite those Merlin 1D
engines in preparation for liftoff
payloads continuing to look healthy
for today's launch attempt
Falcon that is a startup
and with that Falcon 9 has transitioned
into startup weather is looking good
range is ready to support next major
Milestone will be has started
and it sounds as though it looks like we
have the clock has held I believe I
heard a launch abort was called
Now launch abort is not necessarily A
Bad Thing uh
at the point that we are underneath T
minus 60 seconds uh falcon or the ground
team can call and abort if they see
something that doesn't look quite right
so we're going to listen into the loops
a little bit here see if we can find out
more bear with us a moment
and on countdown one this is a launch
director um we've awarded currently
evaluating uh
foreign
hey welcome back folks now if you've
been following along you know that we
had an abort called uh just under the
T-minus 60 second Mark the launch
director called out and an abort
um but the ground teams are still
investigating what happened there now
keep in mind the purpose of a countdown
is to help us catch potential issues
prior to flight there are many many ways
that a launch can go wrong and only one
way that it can go right and given that
we are very cautious on the ground and
if the team or the vehicle sees anything
that looks slightly off you stop the
countdown and try again another day now
again the vehicle and the payload remain
in good health but unfortunately this
will end our launch attempt for today we
do have a backup opportunity tomorrow
just a little bit earlier at 6 15 a.m
Pacific we hope you'll join us for that
one thanks for joining us today and
we'll see you for the next attempt
[Music]
thank you